[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
où nous allons débattre de l'actualité
une actualité qui est passée évidemment
sur le site des élections
présidentielles qui se profile avec
notamment la primaire écologiste et puis
les promesses qu'on voit poindre un peu
partout on parlera aussi d'un livre
qu'il n'ya paraître qui est celui de ce
professeur de philosophie de trappes qui
vient de faire donc paraître ce livre
qui s'appelle lettre d'un hussard de la
république et livre qui paraît au moment
où des élections municipales de vont à
nouveau avoir lieu à trappes après
l'annulation de celle qui avait eu lieu
en mars dernier puis nous avons aussi
d'autres sujets d'actualité avec laurent
mazaury bonjour bonjour vous êtes vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
vous êtes adjoint au maire d'elancourt
et président de télé 78 j'ai tout dit
tout à fait les contribuables des
contres il comme précis et honnête
j'en suis sûr je ressens de la joie dit
bonjour bonjour des éditeurs on va en
dire un mot doit à l' arrêt superbe
superbe livre on peut le dire tout de
suite on peut dire là et puis après
venir deux fois s'est dit un peu d'eau
thierry gonot colonel de gendarmerie qui
étaient quatre ans en poste au cameroun
et qui nous raconte ce qui se passe au
cameroun et soeurs génique qui a lieu au
cameroun dans la salle yeux 100%
cameroun et surtout dans la partie
anglophone du cameroun qui est une
partie sécessionnistes et c'est assez
assez sanglant est assez
voilà c'est une vision du cameroun assez
saisissante en tout cas pour ma part que
je finis à l'arrêt oui c'est un polar il
ya un ingénieur français mais qui se
laisse paralysé voilà
dans ces luttes camerounaise francis
bels walla et c'est donc aux éditions la
joie ni absolument à côté vous nelson
casse pas bonjour bonjour vous êtes
étudiant à l'université de versailles
saint quentin vous êtes membre de l'uni
syndicat plutôt de droite on peut le
dire oui tout à fait le droit toi bats
l'objectif étant de faire reprendre à la
france sa capacité d'avoir un contrôle
sur l'enseignement supérieur
c'est à dire que l'enseignement
supérieur doit transmettre des savoirs
des compétences et l'idéologie n'y a pas
sa place
surtout des idéologies qui vont à
l'encontre
des intérêts nationaux d'accord c'est
panis la mouche
mais ce que je sais c'est qu'il ne sera
probablement pas d'accord avec quentin
des mers bonjour
on les a priori mais on verra s'ils se
vérifient
vous êtes vous êtes vous conseiller
municipal à guillon cauet vous êtes
membre du parti communiste
et puis avec nous on vise you
then communique au qui est félix deltour
et vous êtes membre du bureau
départemental déjà 78 jam ces jeunes
avec macro moins ça
bonjour bonjour et alors il ya il ya des
étudiants il ya professeur c'est vincent
couronne bonjour bonjour un ancien
étudiant aussi à des étudiants
évidemment vous êtes fondateur des
surligneurs et les surligner ressortent
aujourd'hui un livre passionnant alors
on y consacrera une émission d'ici d'ici
quelques semaines sur la politique et la
religion
c'est ça tout à fait c'est un ensemble
de brèves en fait d'une trentaine de
brèves qu'on publie sur les erreurs ou
les preuves les erreurs faites juridique
que font les politiques sur la religion
ou les promesses juridiquement intenable
aussi qu'il peut faire sur la laïcité
voilà donc ça sort ça soit effectivement
aujourd'hui et c'est dans toutes bonnes
librairies d'accord et nous autres nous
y consacrerons une émission début
octobre
sur ce thème de l'avenir politique est
là et la religion
on va aborder évidemment les
présidentielles mais peut-être avant il
ya une étude qui est assez intéressante
sur le vote des jeunes est un livre qui
paraît aux éditions aux arènes qui
s'appelle la fracture de frédéric dabi
et de stewards chaud
alors c'est vrai que le premier
phénomène sur le vote des jeunes c'est
l'abstention
on avait vu que ça va
64% des élections dans la majorité de
drive à la totalité de la population
s'était 84% sur les jeunes s'étaient
déjà 70% au président c'est le ca c'est
absolument énorme je vais peut-être
commencer par pas vous deux
désengager bouffon 1
qu'est ce qui fait que au fond les
jeunes ne s'intéressent pas à la
politique et ne considère que les
élections ne servent à rien quant à des
même si je dois commencer
je pense que la jeunesse est très engagé
comme comme on peut le voir au niveau
associatif et au niveau sur plein de
mobilisation il c'est le présent et je
pense que ce qui manque aux jeunes c'est
l'impression d'être de peser vraiment
dans le débat public notamment des
victoires moi je prendrais un exemple
qui me marquent beaucoup parce que sa
marque aussi les générations peu les
gens plus vieille que moi la question du
cpe par exemple dernière grande
mobilisation qui a fait que la jeunesse
en se mobilisant ans en retrouvant
l'esprit collectif a réussi à gagner
c'était le cpe pour faire reculer ce
projet de loi est depuis ce cpe cpe
c'est pas d'hier et justement et
justement il n'y a pas eu de vraie
victoire des jeunes qui se mobilisent
depuis le cpe et le problème est là
c'est que les jeunes ils se rendent
compte depuis 2006 que à chaque fois
qu'ils sont mobilisés ils n'ont jamais
réussi à obtenir gain de cause et ce qui
peut ce qui créé des déceptions et ce
qui donne ce qu'il veut perdre la
confiance en action collective leon gast
sport alors on va avoir un point
d'accord
d'accord ça va être sur des soldes a
priori vous savez on va être ça va être
sur celui de l'impact que les jeunes ils
veulent avoir sur la politique et c'est
pas que les jeunes parce que l'homme est
un animal social l'homme il veut pouvoir
partager ses idées ses convictions et
veulent il veut que ses convictions
puisse impacter le monde qui les entoure
tout simplement alors au delà de 5 pour
prendre le vote le vote en démocratie
qu'est ce que c'est il ya deux fonctions
du vote via le vote libre dont le libre
choix de ses représentants août se
porter comme tel alors à ce titre là
quand vous êtes un jeune et il faut un
certain devoir d'interprétation essayez
vous mettre dans la peau d'un jeune qui
ne s'intéresse pas du tout à la
politique partisane qu'est-ce qui se
passe est ce qu'on vient vous voir est
ce qu'on essaye de prendre en
considération vos idées vos projets
votre vision qui sont d'ailleurs bien
souvent opposés aux visions que certains
se font dans le milieu politique à
l'intérieur de leur cercle de réflexion
vous pourrez y est totalement enrichir
leur réflexion donc passons faisons
abstraction disant que vous avez adhéré
alors que personne n'est venu vous
chercher essayer de vous comprendre une
fois que vous avez adhéré qu'est ce qui
se passe qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
pour impacter sur le monde qui vous
entoure vous n'avez aucune solution on
ne vous laisse rien faire et comme vous
le disait comme j'ai essayé de vous le
démontrer on veut avoir un impact sur le
monde qui nous entoure c'est pour ça que
les jeunes se sont souvent d'air le
milieu associatif ce que sauf que le
milieu politique est le meilleur milieu
pour avoir un impact à grande échelle et
c'est là on va aller sur le deuxième
facette de ce vote c'est qui doit être à
la fois libre mais il doit être à la
fois motivé on doit comprendre pourquoi
on vote tel candidat et par des
renoncements politique par plusieurs
phénomènes surtout des phénomènes où les
vrais enjeux sont cachées alors des
phénomènes un terme comme notre part de
souveraineté sur le droit interne donc
je comprends votre analyse mais c'est un
peu glauque
on pourrait dire ce que vous dites pour
les pour les gens un peu plus âgé
il ya un phénomène qui est quand même
intéressant c'est que ont regardé les
présidentielles tous les candidats ont
un programme sur les jeunes tout le
monde parle des jeunes en gros tout le
monde par des jeunes sauf les jeunes eux
mêmes sauf les diables mais moi je
voulais quand même réagir sur le fait de
dire par rapport à notre ami à ma droite
c'est que moi j'aimerais que les jeunes
se déterminent pour plutôt que
systématiquement contre et c'est un
petit peu ce qui manque en fait si je
trouve qu'on est souvent dans la
réaction et on est un petit peu moins
dans l'action militante et moi ça fait
plaisir qu'on ait des jeunes ici engagé
peu importe le bord qui sont un gage et
le jour la société pour exprimer des
idées pour porter des projets c'est là
où pour moi c'est à vous de les
entraîner il faut vous puissiez
entraîner tous les autres jeunes
choristes elle conçoit centre votre
engagement politique parce que c'est
comme ça on peut peser quand on
s'exprime toujours contre on bâtit pas
grand chose moi c'est un petit peu ma
déception après après on doit quand même
être optimiste quand on élu local on en
contact des normandes associations et
aussi bien moi dans la partie culturelle
elle en cours de la partie sportive à 50
hors des villes il ya énormément de
jeunes dans les associations qui sont
actifs je trouve que c'est quand même
déjà évidemment c'est vrai bien voilà je
partage son engagement associatif il ya
souvent un engagement d'ailleurs
écologique associatif occire m'ont parlé
aux soldats prêts verts écologiques
félix est toujours votre sentiment
là-dessus mais je suis assez d'accord
sur le fait que ont créé des programmes
qui parle des jeunes mais qui sont pas
réellement à la fois qu'on construit et
en même pas fait pour les jeunes je te
prendrais un exemple et c'est assez vrai
et vous le mettez dans dans vos
différentes études le lot front national
a tendance à mettre énormément les
jeunes en avant dans son programme en
mettant également beaucoup de jeunes en
avant dans sa structure il suffit de
voir des profits comme jordan bardella
mais au final et je ne se retrouve pas
forcément puisqu'on parle d'eux mais on
ne parle pas avec eux ni pour eux c'est
le constat que l'on peut faire dans tous
les partis politiques et une
organisation comme les jeunes avec
macron mais qu'il existe aussi les
jeunes du parti socialiste les jeunes
républicains il faut réussir non pas
seulement à parler des jeunes mais à
faire parler les jeunes et donc en
lésant les mettant plus en avant dans
les décisions mais également dans cette
partie dans cette préparation de la
campagne
2022 je pense que l'enjeu ça va être de
faire parler des jeunes des propositions
pour les jeunes mais sa position aussi
le porte parolat et et de et vecteur de
communication
est ce que au fond les jeux ne se disent
pas que la réalité se passe peut-être
ailleurs que dans la politique
sisi exactement patrice je pense tout à
fait raison un beau delà des analystes
politiques qu'on peut faire sur le
désamour des jeunes pour la politique je
pense que et là je vais prendre ma
casquette un peu de deux chefs d'un
média de directeur de média qui lutte
contre la désinformation bref c'est
l'usagé fait des médias que font les
jeunes aujourd'hui
il y à une étude kantar sofres qui a été
fait en 2021 sur la confiance des
français dans les médias et qui montre
qu'aujourd'hui 34% des français
s'informent principalement via internet
ac les français dans leur ensemble et
moins de 35 ans ces 66 % ce qui fait que
je pense que le fait que les jeunes se
détournent des élus pour aller vers
l'action plutôt de terrain est aussi le
reflet en fait du désamour des jeunes
pour la presse traditionnelle et les
médias traditionnels c'est à dire que il
s'informe essentiellement via internet
via les réseaux sociaux où il retrouve
qui des associations des jeunes leurs
proches leurs voisins etc et avec
lesquels et s'organiser ils agissent et
donc ça c'est un je pense un élément
aujourd'hui fondamental de l'engagement
politique qui se fait en dehors des
institutions classiques traditionnels
parce que ça se fait des journées plus à
partir des réseaux sociaux
d'abord je sais
de l'avis de notre ami c'est vrai que
les jeunes on les entend beaucoup plus
être contre quoi que ce soit beaucoup
quelques pour quelque chose donc ça
s'est élancée la première sur la
deuxième chose c'est que quand on parle
des jeunes c'est vraiment une sorte d'
amalgame c'est comme si on parlait des
vieux qu'est ce qu'il ya de commun entre
un jeune de campagne un jeune
universitaire à halu vs qu un jeune
travailleur et c'est pas grand chose
donc de toujours globalisé comme ça
aurait ses réponses non mais c'est qu'on
a de les utiliser voilà mais c'est quand
même pas très pratique et ensuite là où
je trouve qu'on peut quand même faire un
reproche sur la aux jeunes en règle
générale c'est quand j'entends ce que
dit vincent couronne en dix ans les
jeunes s'informent sur internet mais et
les jeunes les jeunes ont calé hier la
presse la presse existe on est dans une
démocratie il ya une presse écrite une
offre absolument extraordinaire a
quasiment unique au monde en france avec
un éventail de presse qui va de
l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche et
ce temps sans aller ni à l'extrême
rareté extrême gauche on a quand même
des journaux de droite des journaux de
gauche des journaux centriste et c'est
qu'on peut lire sur internet mais moi je
le vois avec mes amis mes étudiants ils
ne lisent rien et sont là et pourquoi
est ce qu'ils ne disent rien alors après
on peut toujours dire bah oui talent
aromatiques mais ils n'ont qu'à lire les
jeunes je veux dire ils sont pas
complètement abrutis vietnam et c'est
trop facile de dire
il ya eu un énorme ici oui on peut on
peut aussi leur dire prenez vous en main
fait quelque chose sortez un peu je dire
arrêtez tout mais pourquoi ça mais
pourquoi l'espèce campêche un jamais de
lire libération de lire les égos fait
comme la filière bois ça ne les
intéresse pas c'est cette chaîne est ce
que est ce que vous lisez la presse vous
affirmez comment par la presse par des
niveaux pour ce qui est un peu plus
anciens pour le coup après les réseaux
sociaux ça permet d'avoir de
l'information rapide mais qu'il faut
toujours recroiser paraissent vite c'est
très important mais quentin après quand
je peins on parle des réseaux sociaux
faut pas oublier que les jeunes sont
aussi abonnés aux grands journaux sous
les réseaux sociaux sur facebook par
exemple on peut suivre son fil
d'actualité les postes de le mouiller et
avoir déjà un premier goût de ce que
c'est donc
les grands médias et ce qui n'empêche
pas de cliquer et pourquoi pas s'abonner
bon pas très clair quand on est étudiant
et s'il veut faire reprendre juste une
petite chose quand on dit que les jeunes
sont souvent contre quand on est quand
on est aussi pour quand on est contre le
cpe on est pour aussi l'égalité dans le
salariat et pas avoir des mimiques trop
de travail pour les jeunes en fait
aujourd'hui dans les dernières réformes
qu'on a proposé aux jeunes s'étaient
c'était baisser leurs droits quand il a
concédé dans le monde du travail s'était
blessé lors droit quand ils vont à
l'université propose que des baisses
donc évidemment oui s'oppose pas ce
qu'ils veulent aussi un monde un monde
plus jolie ils savent qu'ils sont un
pays riche ils veulent qu'il est moyen
que s'est mis en face pour avoir un vrai
avenir
je devrai simplement si on avait fait
cette émission en noir et blanc des
années 60 je n'aurais pas la même chose
en l'état je me souviens quand même de
68 je me souviens de tout bruit ils
pensent qu'à danser pensent qu'à faire
la fesse et les blousons noirs il faut
il s'intéresse pas à la politique ou
alors si il y avait toujours comme ici
des gens passionnés par la vie politique
et créera en nombre restreint bhutto
intellectuel plutôt parisien et c'est là
le découpage entre la province et paris
existait déjà moi je veux savoir
peut-être vincent peut nous le dire
comment est né ce qu'il y ait des
statistiques de l'époque parce que je
rappelle aussi qu'un leur donner le
droit de vote à 21 ans pas avant donc
est ce que la france 18 21 si elles
avaient voté dans les 60's que l'heure
est votée est-ce que rue 66% à tant
d'abstentions j'ai cette expérience un
peu compassé un peu plus tôt être
optimiste je pense qu'effectivement le
taux d'abstention est un exemple mais je
ne suis pas certain que pour autant les
jeunes ne s'intéressent pas plus
peut-être que dans les années 60 à la
vie du quotidien à la politique au sens
noble du terme à la vie de la cité moi
j'ai le sentiment réalité qu'on s'y
intéresse plus c'est peut-être moins
exprimé dans l'époque brigade autre
forme d'engagement mouche valence est
quelque part et quelque part patrice
ensuite on vieillit on vote un peu plus
et ben pourquoi pas après tout ça peut
être aussi un mode d'engagement il est
un petit peu moins démocratiques en
apparence mais je pense qu'il l'est tout
autant en fait je voyais ce petit nice
paul absolument vincent vous avez un
éclairage sur ce que demande et laurent
j'ai pas de statistiques particulière
mais je pense qu'il ya deux paramètres
partiquement important prend en compte
quand on essaie de comparer les années
70 ça aujourd'hui c'est que c'était une
époque aussi de croissance extrêmement
importante et constante jusqu'au premier
choc pétrolier et c'était très facile de
faire des promesses et de pouvoir les
tenir derrière
déjà ça d'un point de vue politique ça
change énormément la donne aujourd'hui
on est dans une politique beaucoup plus
contrainte
budgétairement donc c'est évidemment
c'est pas pareil ça fait moins rêver
évidemment et l'autre paramètre c'est
qu' il n'y avait pas à l'époque internet
il n'y avait pas les réseaux sociaux et
il n'y avait pas aujourd'hui cette fin à
l'époque ce qu'on a aujourd'hui à la
fois de ce qu'on pourrait dire de
pervers un peu dans les réseaux sociaux
ce qui fait que vous êtes dans un espèce
de bulle de filtres qui vous qui nous
qui fait que vous êtes essentiellement
entouré de propos qui vous ressemble et
mais c'était cet effet peut-être parfois
positif qui fait que comme vous êtes
entouré de vos proches sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment via facebook un
essentiellement vous voyez beaucoup de
poches de postes de vos proches ça peut
vous inciter à l'action on a démontré
par exemple que le mouvement des gilet
jaune était né au lendemain d'une
modification de l'algorithme par
facebook et qui faisait que ont favorisé
les postes des proches au détriment de
ceux des médias
jusqu'à comparé les jeunes pourront
arrêter parler de facebook parce qu'il
ya plus un jeune sur facebook donc non
plus il ya de gens un peu plus à la non
mais s'il part à metz a fait je suis
vous parlait déjà celle avec là on se
trompe complètement en l'avenir donc
génération à 110 il ya 21 ans pour
pouvoir baisser alors peut-être que les
disciples peut-être trop tôt finalement
jean charles a beaucoup sur tik tok
j'aimerais rebondir sur l'emploi ce que
vous voulez bien rapidement et que
rapidement alors c'est pour ça que
j'essaye de vous démontrer qu'on a plein
de contraintes intérieures et
extérieures cinéma empêche le bot mais
c'est parce qu'on est face à un
phénomène de société qui commenceront à
mon avis qui commence du passage des
partis en partie de masse en partie de
cadres c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui les
jeunes vont des associations car chacun
peut s'investir dans des associations et
avoir un impact alors qu'aujourd'hui
dans les partis politiques c'est un
repli sur soi c'est on dessine entre
quelques-uns et les jeunes n'ont pas
leur place c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi
la politique des files d'attentes vous
avez intérêt à ce que
le précédent prenne sa retraite est
généralement elle n'est pas à 60 ans
avant que notre place with début faut un
peu pour souvient d'accord pour dire les
choses comme elles sont au fond un peu
fermé sa gueule contre des militants et
attendre comme ça qu'on soit produit et
que en effet des autres laissent la
place aux bas c'est moi je reviens juste
très rapidement sur sa gorge comme que
20 des mères ou des repas ou papa aux
particuliers à partir beaucoup attaqué à
l'époque pourtant son travail ou
démocratique aujourd'hui dans mon vécu
et c'est vrai qu'il a changé ça fait
sept ans que je suis au parti communiste
est toujours eu ma voix de danse jour
but dire clairement ce que je voulais
jamais été menacé ou quoi que ce soit
donc on peut vivre si vous êtes élu et
je suis aujourd'hui élus de mon fait
confiance en plus elle même quand
j'aurai quand je parlais librement aussi
moins nombreux au parti communiste que
dans d'autres parties donc
que tout le moins d'autres partis
beaucoup de parties jouées sont plus bas
que nous moi je remarque quand même bon
j'avais des choses à dire mais j'ai
oublié non mais on peut rebondir là
dessus parce que quand je parle du
passage de parti de masse en partie de
cadres en effet le rpr dans les années
80 était à 9 cents mille adhérents
presque 900 mille adhérents 855 le parti
communiste dans les années 70 c'était à
500 mille adhérents on voit aujourd'hui
en parti communiste à 40 et quelques
mille adhérents
le descendant du rpr à une centaine de
milliers d'adhérents on voit très bien
qu'on s'est replié sur un entre soi et
nous ailleurs nous d'ailleurs les
primaires qui répondent à la crise en
effet deux de ces partis politiques qui
ne sont plus capables de choisir
eux-mêmes leurs propres candidats et
donc on va on va aborder justement cette
présidentielle avec la politique avec
peut-être une foire à la démagogie qui
s'ouvre avec des propositions à droite à
gauche
[Musique]
alors il ya eu dimanche le résultat du
premier tour de la primaire écolo avec
deux qualifiés dont qui sont jadot et
sandrine rousseau
c'est assez intéressant alors l'ailé les
commentaires sont un peu les mêmes c'est
à dire que cette propension des écolos à
choisir plutôt le candidat qui fera le
moins de voix cette paire allemands
et c'est vrai que il ya une radicalité
en tout cas qui s'est exprimé dans ce
choix puisque sandrine rousseau était la
candidate la plus radicale par des
écologistes jadot étant celui qui
probablement s'il était désigné ferait
le plus de voix et qui s'adresse à toute
la société elle s'adresse plutôt aux aux
militants quand vous allez analyser ce
ses résultats justement
avez vous levé un peu dit patrice c'est
la radicalité contre la mode et la
modération néanmoins je rappellerai que
tous les candidats écologistes sont tous
engagés à respecter a fait appliquer la
plateforme écologistes dans lequel
l'ensemble des futurs aux mesures sont
roux listés et il ya à l'intérieur à se
rendre de mesures assez radical
j'entendais ce matin par exemple la
création du statut légal des animaux ça
paraît comme ça une petite blagounette
mais ça nous amène très rapidement une
forme de véganisme dans lequel si on
devait demain tu es des vaches par
exemple monture est forcément des êtres
juridiquement existant peut se poser des
questions des déviances éventuelles
après il ya aussi un point qui est assez
politiquement un petit peu inquiétant
c'est que madame rousseau par exemple ne
s'est jamais caché de ses proximités
avec jean luc mélenchon donc derrière
une porte autre chose et quelque part on
éclate un petit peu le parti écologiste
après telles que les choses sont et ont
pu être montré le ce week-end on voit
que les statistiques d'un point de vue
vote absolue ne plaident pas en la
faveur d'une victoire de yannick jadot
parce que si on a s'amuse à faire le
report des voix et réalmont
nationalisation est allé au bout en
scène delphine batho qui est une
décroissance eric woerth est plutôt la
gauche
delà de la pour une aiguille écologie
assez radicale aussi oui en gros si on
regarde les choses seraient nous reçoit
de fortes chances d'être élu d'être
d'être désigné en tout cas et on importe
chance de s'amuser parce que avec son
âne rousseau je vais dire tous les jours
c'est une nouvelle déclarations
farfelues ces quelques jeunes donc là la
version n'est pas si j'étais si je
votais l'écologie s'est un peu effondré
de de cette probable victoire de
sandrine rousseau mais en tant qu
observateur extérieur je me dis chaque
semaine amène avec soin son lot de
déclarations
abracadabrantesque la dernière en date
était bas c'est mieux d'avoir les
terroristes talibans chez nous comme si
on peut les surveiller enfin je veux
dire c'est la fin c'est une écologiste
qui osent tout c'est une artère
quoiqu'en se désaxer l'écologie
féministes et les que juni des
colonialistes et ce sont deux grands
courants fin nous ne croit important
l'écologie d'ailleurs il est
effectivement effrayante enfin avec ce
qu elle est radicale en tout cas mais
hélas hélas cette frénésie enfin c'est
le lentilles spécifié le ccdh et
racisées c'est le set véganisme s'est
tenue une société enfin que c'est pas
d'humanisme du fascisme mais oui c'est
toute la soca parti n'a osé dire ce
qu'elle a dit c'est du parti commises
par exemple je ne suis pas communiste
mais au moins les propos aujourd'hui
humanise pour une forme de république
quand on est bien entendu pas d'accord
mais mais sa porte quand même la france
là ce que j'entends c'est terrible couac
en jeu lundi génie non je veux dire mais
mais réellement dire mon ennemi c'est le
mâle blanc de plus de 50 ans je désigne
des ennemis
mais des gens qui désigne des ennemis
aujourd'hui en france et qui les hymnes
les ennemis qui vont qui classifie les
gens dans des cases mais mes mates 11 55
01 m on prend vos n'utilisons êtes elle
applique et elle applique ce
raisonnement à ce qu'on fait d'eux des
ressources naturelles le aussi du corps
des femmes quand elles sont violées mais
aussi
du corps des médias nathalie arthaud va
passer pour une modérée avec que
sandrine rousseau c'est ça qui va être
extraordinaire des dépenses sur les
soins de bouche c'est autant sortis pour
là dessus c'est tout ce que l'on combat
chez lui ni c'est alors à bâle il n'y a
pas quelqu'un pour le défendre
premièrement c'est la division
horizontale du peuple français pourquoi
c'est la division du peuple du peuple
français parce que vous avez comme il a
été très bien dit d'un côté les blancs
d'un côté et noir c'est l'anti humanisme
total c'est de toute la série fame nos
côtés les hommes aussi vous pourrez sans
doute l'épreuve la potée les hommes mais
ça peut se décliner sous plein d'aspects
différents tout cela ça découle de
sartre tout simplement sartre dont sa
biographe dira à la fin de sa vie avec
avec les remords qu'il a eu durant la
seconde guerre mondiale il pas plus
d'intérêt aux noirs américains qu aux
prolétaires français et ça fait pas du
tout rupture avec l'anti humanisme et
universalisme de foucault on est
totalement dans la continuité c'est
assez semblable même aux indigènes
derniers publics à mettre en place faut
pas tout à fait dire que c'était
différent pour les terriers français il
a été il a été dans les îles était à
boulogne billancourt et c'est bon on va
pas faire un débat sur sartre
sartre il sait plus où ça nous rajeunit
pas félix del toro et vincent couronne
félix la question de cette primaire elle
pose aussi la mobilisation des militants
d'europe écologie et verts ils sont
environ 30000 si on prend les derniers
chiffres du parti là on voit qu'il ya eu
à peu près 120 mille votants ouais
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
qui est allé voter à cette primaire des
écologistes et pour expliquer peut-être
le résultat de sandrine rousseau qui est
la plus extrême on peut soit penser que
ce sont des gens qui sont pas forcément
adhérents et europe ecologie les verts
mais qui partagent une partie des
opinions de la gauche indigéniste et
écologistes ou alors on peut aussi
émettre l'hypothèse que des gens ont
décidé d'investir disons 2 euros pour
voir arriver un candidat europe ecologie
les verts qui aurait le moins de chances
possibles et
c2 en tout cas de faire un score
conséquent à la primaire à la
présidentielle et je pense que c'est le
on va revoir le même problème qu on les
convoque à europe ecologie les verts
depuis 30 40 voire encore plus de temps
c'est que pour ce qui est des élections
locales et européennes qui portent sur
des sujets spécifiques il arrive à
proposer une vision qui rassemble des
gens en dehors de leur parti arrivé aux
présidentielles lorsqu'il faut
construire un programme cohérent et
réunir de michèle rivasi anti-vaccins
jusqu'au pro nucléaire d'europe écologie
les verts il n'y arrive plus ils se
tournent souvent vers la candidature la
plus radicale celle qui attire à la fois
une seule internes et les sympathisants
de l'externe
moi je vois deux choix aussi dans ce
scrutin d'abord c'est la grande division
data mieux élevé puisqu'on a quasiment
un quart sur chaque candidat oui ça
monte il y apparaissait tout ça 22
autour de 20 points -2 32% et on voit la
question de l'engagement donc moi je
suis militant et donc je suis
extrêmement attachée à la démocratie
dans un parti et nouveau droit qu'on a
quand on est militant et quand on paie
sa cotisation mais ça me suis toujours
un peu triste de me dire bah quand on
est à élever qu'est ce qui pousse les
gens à devenir adhérents puisque
finalement quelqu'un qui donnera
seulement 2 euros alors qu on sait
qu'une cotisation c'est généralement
plus en donnant deux euros un jour on
peut voter pour le candidat alors donc
en fait être être militant au sein de
élevé où être en dehors ça ne change
rien je suis comme attaché à ces
questions de démocratie dans le parti
c'est la question des primes de sa dette
c'est devoir parler d'ailleurs tout à
fait raison quand on est adhérent ou non
à des traitements qui il va être
possible aussi de pouvoir participer au
second tour en payant deux euros entre
les deux tours sans avoir prêché gros
ballons bleus le collège électoral et fx
et c de même
nom ces deux mêmes qui voteront ou
deuxième tour il fallait s'inscrire
avant en tout cas on notera qu'à la
primaire de la droite françois fillon
avait été désigné il y avait des
millions d'euros mis au point trois
millions de participants tout à fait
personne n'est allé
justifier le choix des républicains
pour les plaindre en disant qu'il y
avait peut-être une manipulation de
millions de gauchistes à la première
balle au matin non après il y aura
probablement mais c'était marginal il ya
probablement eu des gens qui préférait
que ce soit juppé qui a été vu tjp qui
n'étaient pas forcément des membres de l
est mais il ya eu 7 est tout à fait
marginale et c'était des premières
qu'avec plus pour l'eau ou bien bien
organisé même le même si après on peut
s'interroger sur les primaires est ce
que ça ne favorise pas justement les
candidats les plus radicaux ce qui était
le cas de fillon en 2017 quel cas de
sandrine rousseau aujourd'hui vincent
couronne
ah oui moi je petites remarques
liminaires c'est que nous est là autour
de cette table de deux de nos écrans
nous sommes en fait en tant que mâle
blanc absolument non mais ainsi qu'une
erreur d'aujourd'hui
je veux dire c'est que nous sommes les
ennemis désignés de sandrine rousseau de
coucher pas sûr que soient les plus
objectifs pour pour commenter sa ces
propositions du coup je me permets de
botter en touche
et donc de dire que
comment dire
en fonction de la personnalité qui sera
désigné par oew élevé il faut penser
aussi au coup d'après et est ce que la
gauche sera en mesure de se rassembler
pour le pr le premier tour de la
présidentielle effectivement si c'est
sandrine rousseau qui est désignée
candidate d'europe écologie les verts ça
me paraît assez compliqué quand même
qu'elle puisse se ranger derrière
éventuellement anne hidalgo 1 qui sera à
quai la candidature socialiste aurait
matin sur france inter
je meurs je le redirai anne hidalgo l'un
est là elle a dit qu'elle se
présenterait qu'elle est là jusqu'au
bout ou presque peut pas dire ça va pas
dire qu'au deuxième tour elle va pas
appeler à voter d'abord qu'elle ne
voulait pas se réfugier à ce que vous
pensez le
nom oui je me sens loto tous ensemble et
déjà les assurances fiction côté disque
disait voudra sans couronne et je pense
que si c'est sandrine rousseau qui est
désignée comme candidate verte c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour la gauche
si oui on voit bien les sauvageons
yannick jadot était plutôt devant le
candidat socialiste ou la candidate
socialiste
si c'est sandrine rousseau on peut
estimer qu'elle fera de 3%
cassant vincent et et l'autre chose en
fait que je voulais dire aussi c'est que
quand on compte on dit que effectivement
cette primaire c'est un petit peu la
foire à la radicalité ouvrait une
promotion à la radicalité
c'est pas très étonnant en fait parce
que ces primaires ne font que refléter
en fait la présidentielle qu'il ya
derrière et notre système en france
présidentialiste fait que ben un peu
comme des comme des lessives alignés sur
un rayon ça sera à celle qui va se
vendre deux de mieux se vendre qui sera
acquis ce qui sera achetée et donc c'est
ce concours-là de la radicalité il est
aussi il se retrouve derrière un
lorsqu'on lors de l'élection
présidentielle et donc rien d'étonnant à
ce qu'on le voit d'étain en fait sur les
sur les primaires même d'europe écologie
les verts comme parti qui est contre ce
système présidentialiste ou alors on va
justement parlé d' anne hidalgo parce
que c'est vrai que non dans ses prémices
de l'élection présidentielle il ya comme
ça des propositions qu'il faut parler
dont on ne sait pas si elles sont
applicables ou pas et là il ya notamment
cette proposition d'anne hidalgo 2 blé
le salaire des enseignants
on a calculé le coût c'est quand même
150 milliards d'euros dans un pays qui
crème déjà surendettés ou alors on peut
augmenter les impôts mais il faudrait il
faudrait dire c'est à dire comment les
finances est ce que ça vous paraît une
proposition réaliste ou une proposition
qui existent fait pour faire parler de
soi loreau mazaury oui alors premières
constatations il ya un vrai décrochage
de rémunération effectivement oui dû
commencer en général par rapport à
l'allemagne du corps enseignant au père
ok ça c'est clair un deuxième
constatation quand on est à la tête ou
quand on s'apprête plus ou moins
d'ailleurs parce que c'est pas encore
très clair être adoubé par le parti
sioniste comme candidat officiel on doit
parler à son électorat évidemment les
victoires du parti socialiste il est
dans l'éducation de ses points dans le
dernier électorat identifié qui reste on
peut comprendre qu'il fallait avoir un
bisou monde qui arrive à des professeurs
pour attirer pour arriver au four au
moins 5% des voix cette deuxième sujet
après le troisième sujet réfléchir à un
doublement de la rémunération quand on
est endetté à 2400 milliards version
basse de la version gouvernementale
actuelle mais on peut comprendre un plan
de relance et on a dû effectivement on a
lu le quoi qu'il en coûte mais encore
heureux qu'on l'a connue parce que si on
aurait pu d'entreprise ou quasiment main
je parle même pas des tpe et de pme bon
on voit bien que cette mesure n'est pas
financé mais on en a eu d'autres à
l'époque du parti socialiste avec le
revenu d'existence minimum d'existence
dont on savait pas trop comment ils se
financer on est dans la logique et
malheureusement je pense que elle n'aura
pas le leur a pas le monopole des
propositions délirante et qu'on va en
voir arriver elle en aura certainement
d'autres elle mêle il y en aura d'autre
part ailleurs dans d'autres partis voilà
la cause mis la barre assez haut havel a
commencé très fort il faut faire il faut
effectivement qu'on puisse parler d'elle
vous savez en phase est là et les
zemmour qui vont survivre et longue de
logique est le commercial et le terminal
en marketing voilà c'est justement
irréaliste justement est ce qu est ce qu
on n'est pas dans cette
logique d'une campagne présidentielle de
la campagne présidentielle
qui consistent souvent il faut faire
rêver en gros 1
si on veut être si vous être élu et donc
est ce qu'on n'est pas prelytis pas
plutôt le n'importe quoi que le que le
sérieux que le rationnel tous les
candidats qui se présentent en vous
promettant un torrent de larmes et de
ces générale ce soir mon l'élu la
dernière fois on a essayé vous rappelez
il y avait deux surenchère il y avait on
va supprimer supprimer x centaines de
milliers de postes de fonctionnaires
10000 20000 trop fillon genre oui mais
après rappelez vous à chaque débat y
avait celui qui en rajoute avec le plus
et puis il ya des sujets qu'on veut pas
aborder mais il faudra aborder c'est le
nombre de construction de places de
prison 20 milles 35 1115 mouvement alors
cette fois ci on essaie autre chose on
essaie effectivement non pas le
travailler plus pour gagner plus mais on
va distribuer on va raser gratis en a ça
dans toutes les campagnes électorales et
dans le sens que de me parlait tout à
l'heure vincent commandes c'est une
forme de radicalité aussi on a la
qualité de la proposition infinançable
rapidement démoli qui al'avantage par
contre de terence en un second très
court très bien être passé sur tous les
réseaux sociaux et dans toutes les
médailles et d'ailleurs nous mêmes on
regarde et on en débat aujourd'hui on
parle lorsqu'il ya eu c'est très
efficace il ya une corrélation évidente
avec le niveau de dan hidalgo dans les
sondages et l'énormité de la proposition
c'est à dire qu'un candidat qui fait 7
ou 8% d'intentions de vote bah oui il
peut il aurait pu dire on va tripler le
salaire d'ailleurs fait dire ça monte
des bancs allons-y surprendre 2010 être
regardés fillon personnes de regarder
fillon et puis un jour il dit imogen tôt
le général de gaulle mis en examen de ce
jour là tout le monde la regarde et il
est moindre dans les 107 l'idée était
finalement le candidat désigné de la
droite quant à des mets alors vous en
tant que que comme de gauche au fond
finalement proche probablement des
enseignants ces baisses que c'est une
proposition qui vous paraît réaliste à
ça je vais quand même revenir sur sur la
base en 1981 un prof qui gagnent environ
2 smic aujourd'hui les 1,2 smic le
rappelait qu'un proviseur c'est un bac +
5 mega qui à l'avenir de notre pays
entre ses mains jouées avec leur fils à
gogo qui est difficile avec des
conditions de travail qui sont de plus
en plus difficile on se plaint
aujourd'hui notamment dans nos villes
populaires que on manque de profs les
l'absentéisme et ennui finalement cette
égalité da public et d'entre tous les
jeunes de france parce qu'ils n'ont pas
des gens qui sont vraiment qualifier
qu'on l'est et qui ont vraiment
et qu'ils sont suffisamment rémunéré
pour ce qu'ils font je veux pas revenir
sur la question de doubler ou pas c'est
une question qui pour moi plus
économique et je pense pas vraiment
mettant ce non plus pour trancher le
débat mais il ya une vraie question de
comment prend en compte les professeurs
et comment en fait oui il ya une vraie
cassure de la république c'est avant
tout ses professeurs la république c'est
avant tout la formation de ces jeunes et
donc si on n'est pas d'ailleurs les
moyens pour éduquer nos jeunes pas
forcément on a une jeunesse qui va
décrocher de la république et c'est là
qu'on arrive dans tous les dangers avons
parlé de ça il ya une solution qui
équivaut plus plus peut-être plus simple
qui est la solution allemande c'est à
dire qu'ils sont mieux payés beaucoup
mieux payés que les français mais il
travaille beaucoup plus ils ont beaucoup
plus de présence dans le bain dans les
établissements est ce que quelqu'un
aurait le courage de dire aux
enseignants on peut vous augmentez mais
il faudra travailler plus quand même
besoin de faire ses preuves parce qu'on
a quand même le premier budget de la
nation et que 5 milliards je rappelle
que le classement on est dégradée tous
les ans de ce 27e pays des à la roumanie
en matière de résultats cussler
bizarrement voilà bon quand même fou
quand même se le rappeler et puis
chanteur notre ami la raison le film il
ya une partie des professeurs qui sont
cons un concours d'entrée très difficile
mais la proposition s'adresse à
l'ensemble du corps enseignant et
compris le personnel qui travaille dans
les écoles donc je rappelle que derrière
on a les atsem en accélérera les
animateurs et je rappelle qu'on a les
maîtres d'école dont aujourd'hui on peut
pas dire que ce soient les mieux formés
à puisqu'elle est limite on pourrait
tous ept mesdames et messieurs bien sûr
ils sont aux diversités mais peut-être
n'ai-je pas d'éducation pour être que je
peux être maître d'école si j'ai bac + 2
non on ne trouve plus personne est
aujourd'hui dernier point on a supprimé
des iufm avec des connaisseurs que si on
à réformer l'école normale supérieure
appelée vous de ce cursus est là on est
dans les chars la république dont on
parlera tout à l'heure et effectivement
de gens qui étaient passionnés qui
savait emmené avec eux des m aujourd'hui
ils ont disparu conclusion nos écoles
est évident avec et non mais qui était
difficile mais qui est très passionnant
et une partie des enfants étaient
retirés pour mettre dans privé parce que
le public effectivement des tpe la
hauteur ce qui fait qu'on en tire vers
le bas public temps comment sont pas
rénovés effectivement la façon dont on
donne des cours à reformer les
professeurs à donner des cours de
qualité à retrouver cet engouement et
assureront aussi dans nos collèges le
respect du professeur ce que loin d'être
gagné dans certains quartiers ici on
connaît défi qui fait que l'on aille je
pense que probablement notre ami de
travaux vous en parlais tout à l'heure
patrice pourra nous impliquer dans
lequel niveau difficulté se trouve avant
de se dire qu'on va doubler le salaire
moi je suis à ses vacances en fait qu'à
la fois pour peut-être travailler plus
il faut travailler mieux surtout et pour
travailler mieux il faut donner les
chances aux maîtresses d'école aux
professeurs aux personnels d'éducation
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui dans la
quantité au le ou les aujourd'hui de
remplir ses missions pourquoi on n'a pas
assez de profs parce que le taux
d'absentéisme est énorme mais pouvoir on
a beaucoup d'absentéisme est
certainement ceux qui veulent pas
travailler mais ceux qui ne veulent plus
travailler parce qu'il ya aussi des
professions médicales est très difficile
d'aller en face d'autres médecins dans
certaines de nos classes vaut le savoir
moi je vais dans des collèges
représenter 50 on y vit je vous assure
que parfois quand on arrive à l'entrée
du collège on n'est pas même nous on ne
vit pas super je me connais je vais
passer un bon moment je vais passer la
courge à l'entrée voilà c'est dit avec
la perte d'autorité et est peut-être un
membre de se tient au sida ias qui n'ont
pas trop long s'il y avait un sujet que
les que les candidats devraient porter
c'est justement celui de la réforme
d'une question nationale par le
ministère mais les questions régionales
l'entièreté de l'éducation nationale ça
c'est un projet d'un candidat
présidentiel au delà du doublement des
rémunérations vincent corrode vous
galant enseignants et enseignés donc
vous êtes bien placés là si vous savez
très bien que oui c'est pas la rodia pas
très riche quand on enseigne
c'est clair que vous faites pas ça pour
s'enrichir c'est intéressant d'ailleurs
que l'on parle d'abord des enseignants
du secondaire ou du primaire est prêt il
supérieur qui eux aussi font partie des
enseignants les moyens les moins bien
payés d'europe mais sur la rémunération
des enseignants je pense que ça cache
aussi une différence majeure entre la
france et l'allemagne dans le système
éducatif
c'est que le système éducatif doit subir
c'est tout simplement la géographie
l'allemagne un pays plus petits avec
plus de monde la france est un pays
territorialement plus grand avec plus de
zones rurales et
et bien une étude avait montré que cela
nécessitait en france le fait qu' il est
vingt mille établissements scolaires de
plus qu en allemagne du fait de cette
géographie et donc du coup ça nécessite
forcément des classes plus petites et
des enseignants qui est hydra on est
dans des formats plus petit et c'est
dans des zones rurales et donc ça c'est
ce qui fait qu'en france la gestion de
l'éducation nationale beaucoup plus cher
qu'en allemagne où le poids du salaire
en allemagne et plus les plus est plus
fort par rapport à la gestion voilà donc
avant peut-être de penser aux de
réfléchir à l'augmentation du ca la
raison d'être réfléchir sur tout mais
comme le disait laurent a réformé en
fait tout ce système qui est très
coûteux effectivement c'est l'exact eau
et
en prend deux secondes je dirais que
pour revenir sur l'énormité même si elle
pose une vraie question sur le statut
des enseignants et leurs salaires
l'énormité de la proposition d'anne
hidalgo en fait elle trouve sa racine
dès la prise des élections municipales
c'est déjà une stratégie qui avait été
mis en place par anne hidalgo qui avait
fait beaucoup de mesures choc pour paris
de telle manière à rassembler
l'électorat de gauche et aussi à obliger
les candidats de droite ou du centre à
aller toujours vers aussi plus de
radicalité dans la contestation des
propositions ou dans d'autres
propositions et cette manière de
d'éclater l'électorat c'est aussi une
manière de le centralisé autour d'elle
donc à voir si ça fonctionnera pour
l'élection présidentielle mais c'est une
stratégie qui a déjà porté ses fruits
pour les municipales pour la candidate
hidalgo
alors bien sûr des internautes et on est
dans l'effet d'annoncé tout le monde l'a
noté également il faut réformer le
système éducatif français qui est bien
trop coûteux et j'irai même plus loin on
parle d'éducation nationale mais ce
n'est pas à l'école d'éduquer les
enfants c'est aux parents premièrement
première chose est de zéro le personne
ne dit le contraire l'objet donc il faut
se recentrer sur les savoirs
fondamentaux il m'a arrêté d'avoir un
devoir sur deux sur le développement
durable même si c'est une cause très
importante quand on est dans le primaire
en tout cas deuxième chose si vous
augmentez les salaires des enseignants
c'est sûr de 10 à 20% mais il faut avoir
des gages
dernière il faut par exemple que ces
enseignants soient mieux formés pour
pouvoir accueillir les personnes en
situation de handicap au sein des
classes il faut arrêter la séparation
systématique des élèves il faut pouvoir
faire du dépistage dès l'entrée en
primaire il faut pouvoir intégrer chaque
et des paysages de pommes dépistage d
handicap visible et invisible de chaque
élève il ya 80% de handicap invisible
aujourd'hui à l'école une partie de
ceux-ci sont placés dans des classes
qu'on maintient ulysse donc ils sont
séparés des autres élèves même leur cour
de récréation sont séparés des autres
élèves pour pas que les autres
n'est de crainte et qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est qu'on pourrait intégrer tout
à fait ces élèves là à l'intérieur de
classe classique mais par exemple
seulement en mathématiques ou si non
seulement en français si c'est en
mathématiques qu'ils ont des problèmes
or aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans un
système éducatif très coûteux parce que
tout le système administratif français
fonctionne pareil on est dans un moule
et il faut que ça fonctionne pour tout
le monde pareil sauf que ça ne marche
pas et on a les mêmes propositions du
côté du gouvernement par exemple sur les
infirmières et l'augmentation des
salaires c'est une très bonne chose
parce que focaliser un meilleur salaire
parce que c'est très compliqué pour les
personnes de première ligne mais
l'intérêt pour la france c'est pas
d'avoir des personnels mieux payés c'est
d'en avoir plus c'est va avoir une
efficacité certaine c'est de pouvoir
avoir des notations des meilleures
conditions de travail or aujourd'hui on
en est aux abois améliorer le système
c'est ce que vous même sur sur l'école
ce que je suis à lyon pas d'accord sur
les déjà sur le fantasme de la moitié
sur les log durable on n'a pas eu la
même école sûrement ce que moi on est
comme j'ai fait plein de choses j'ai pas
parlé que de développement du ray lane
est un petit peu bah je la suis aussi je
suis aussi dans une école enfin en tant
qu'élu ont ensuite des écoles aussi
parce que je vois n'est pas non plus on
pas d'élire comme ça et aussi je veuille
revenir sur le sol et les savoirs
fondamentaux pas faut quand même
rappeler qu' on n'est pas tous égaux
dans nos familles et des familles qui
ont peut-être culturel qui est énorme et
d'autres qui n'en manque pas donc avoir
une école qui ne donne que les maths et
le français c'est dire qu'il y aura des
enfants courront le droit d'aller à
l'opéra coup droit d'aller au théâtre
parce que leurs parents les emmèneront
les enfants qui n'auront pas le droit
donc une école évidemment que l'école
est de faire autre chose à l'école on
doit faire de là et je suis très heureux
d'avoir fait de la musique de la
philosophie d'abord fait négatifs mais
totalement anormal j'ai pu siffler en
tête quand on voit le nombre d'enfants
qui arrive en 6e et qui savent pas lire
voilà donc à l'ifo plus d'école il faut
plus qu'il faut surveiller mais c'est
face au cannet zatlers je rejoins notre
ami c'est vrai que d'apprendre à lire ça
me paraît quand même la base et c'est
totalement aberrant et que ça c'est pas
forcément la faute de pierre paul ou
jacques
c'est aussi un peu la faute de certains
enseignants n'est pas normal qui est
arrivé en sixième les orques des élèves
de ce1 métrage priorités vous êtes
totalement aberrant ce daaf activement
c'est juste qu'elle est sortie l'entrée
en sixième il faut avoir les
fondamentaux à voir à lire écrire
compter et effectivement vous avez
raison en partir des siennes la partie
de la vue on rouvre son ensemble des
matières parce qu'en fait la barrière
elle est que justement les enfants
peuvent pas proposer parce qu'ils n'ont
pas les savoirs fondamentaux ne peuvent
pas attendre le règlement et il faut
rester là dessus et je pense qu'il faut
c'est tellement fondamentale on a
tellement décriée à l'époque la réforme
haby du collège et c'est alors qu'au
contraire ils ouvraient il ouvrait sur
tous ces savoirs il ouvre mais il faut
savoir lire et réécouter sinon je peux
pas comprendre on sait que ça va c'est
pour ça avec force comme auteur d'abord
et le reste après
faut-il que effectivement on apprenne
aux gens moi je suis désolé j'ai oublié
le nom de cette méthode d'éducation que
nous avons dans certaines cases où il ya
plus de tabia plus de chaises tout le
monde est par terre rappelez moi parce
que je mets toujours son nom il ya
plusieurs écoles devant théoricienne
s'orienter joris magnifique mais quand
est-ce qu'on avait redit mais quand
est-ce qu'on interdit ça m'est donc
nommer les et les classes montessori il
ya des villes c'est pas le cas est en
cours je sais pas si on a vu en cours
j'en sais rien mais je veux passer je
pense m vila les allées on la doit à
sannois ya plein de classe montessori et
puis alors il ya une espèce de
comptabilisation ça quand vous avez deux
mètres et écoles font du beau temps
serré les hommes sont obligés de le
faire et tous l'ont fait du montessori
enfin vous avez essayé d'écrire et les
dolly votre père c'est comme une méthode
qui a fait ses preuves s'il probablement
pas une méthode pour tout le monde croit
le même pas une méthode
non mais hier il ya des écoles
pour ceux qui veulent le volant après
tout pas
l'école publique c'est surtout parce
qu'il faudrait pour une formation
incroyable pour être montré du côté
sourire voilà voilà allez on arrête sur
ce sujet parce que je voudrais qu'on
quand quelqu'un parle c'est passionnel à
l'école qu'on parle d'eux on va parler
d'un prof on va parler un pauvre didier
lemaire le le prof de trappes qui se
livrent
[Musique]
à la didier lambert vous en souvenez 1
ct ce professeur de philosophie de
trappes qui disait qu'il avait été
menacé quelques semaines après
l'attentât qui avait coûté la vie à
samuel pâtit ça fait une créer une
polémique
il a finalement décidé de quitter son
enseignement à trappes et là il publie
un livre chez robert laffont qui
s'appelle lettre d'un hussard de la
république
il dit vous l'avez j'ai été professeur
de philosophie attrapé j'ai petit à
petit pris conscience d'une poussée de
l'islamisme au sein de mon lycée dans un
contexte d'attentats j'ai constaté que
ma robe relation avec les élèves tout
comme leur relation à la discipline
philosophique je me suis retrouvé dans
une position où il m'était devenu très
difficile d'enseigner la philosophie en
classe
alors c'est un livre qui n'arrivent pas
à n'importe quel moment il faut le
rappeler parce qu'il ya une échéance
politique qui va des voix la trappe les
élections municipales ont été annulés il
ya d'autres élections au mois d'octobre
évidemment ce livre arrive à ce moment
là mais au delà de ça
c'est vrai que c'est une affaire qui
avait beaucoup fait parler
avec une division d hier de la société
il y avait les pros le maire les
antilles le maire ce qu'ils disaient
mimos qui disait ben oui c'est vrai on
peut plus enseigner dans certains dans
certains lycées non au delà tout ça dont
on va bien évidemment parler moi j'ai eu
le lachance 20 entre guillemets d'avoir
des étudiants qui avaient eu ce monsieur
parce que ma cliente première année à
l'iut de rambouillet qui ont eu ce
qu'ils m'ont dit nous on n'a eu comme
prof l'année dernière on est comme
projet nous et pour eux cette étape
c'était un personnage globalement il y
avait cinq élèves qu'il avait eue en
terminale au delà de tout ce qui pouvait
dire sur le problème spécifique à la
ville de trappes à l'islamisme et c'est
ce qu'il est choqué et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya peut-être aussi il ne prend
même plus compliqué c'est qu'ils ne
comprenaient strictement rien à ses
cours de philo 1 voilà et et donc il
avait déplacé le débat d'actions dia
mais comme on ne comprenait rien il nous
parlait nüvi il fallait se conduire
comme des lions etc et il avait un
discours visiblement passé difficilement
vis-à-vis de sa classe il donc ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que ça a
probablement un peu discréditer sa
parole sur le rêve parce que les élèves
sont dit il nous on comprend déjà parce
qu'il dit là alors quand il parle
d'autre chose voilà et puis ça c'est
assez intéressant et l'autre chose c'est
qu'ils sont focalisés sur une erreur qui
l'a reconnu c'est qu'en fait il avait
assuré qu à trappes et plus de coiffure
mixte est en fait il y en a voilà et du
coup les étudiants aussi là ils sont dix
bas et il ment parce que c'est pas vrai
il y en a ils m'ont montré les photos
maudit voyez en a l'air donc voilà sur
une erreur qui l'a reconnu très vite le
2 août quatre jours les bons oui
peut-être me suis trompé là dessus mais
sur le fond et il ne revenait pas sur ce
qu'il avait dit mais voilà ces deux
éléments qui sont qui sont assez
importants c'est aussi la nature même du
du prof qui est outil qu'il ne faisait
pas forcément l'unanimité peut-être une
question de niveau aussi je sais pas de
l'ordre oui alors je me souviens de ma
propre professeur de philo elle était un
peu perché aussi parce que les premiers
contrats et quelques-uns qui a les
premiers contacts avec la philo en
terminale es bien et pousse trop ça va
très bien je sais on connaît pas la
matière on connaît pas effectivement
souvent ils s'engagent à vous dire
comportez-vous c'est vrai ça va au delà
bah lacour j'ai souvent il ya des
philosophes qui sont pas des bons fait
deux offres qui sont pas forcément des
bons enseignants oui oui c'est un soleil
qui ferme la philosophie c'est de forcer
nier les séries philosophie c'est pas
d'enseignement effectivement après ça
n'enlevait à ce qu'il avait dit où l'on
connaît c'est tellement je t'aime de
vous projetiez jeu facile et dans les
spectateurs voix et l'image du lycée de
la plaine de nos fonds connais les
problèmes qu'on a au lycée de la plaine
2 nov on sait les difficultés qu'il y a
reconnaît effectivement les tendances
fortes qui s'affrontent là-bas et
effectivement les tendances alors il
cela mistou religieuses ou culturelles
etc les problématiques d'assimilation
d'intégration d'assimilation de cette
amo horrible d'intégration pour faire
des citoyens français avoue connaître
toutes ces difficultés il en a été
effectivement un moment donné celui qui
l'a révélé à tra et déjà à l'époque dans
un contexte combiné politique politique
mais quel que soit le maire de trappes
d'hier et quel que soit bien d'autres
apps de demain ces problèmes là ils
existent on les connaît et on est là
j'espère en tant qu'élu pour faire en
sorte qu'ils disparaissent et pour faire
que tous les trappistes de demain soient
des citoyens au même titre que tous les
habitants de la france et le creuset
républicain ce lieu fondamental qui est
on en parlait à l'instant c'est ça la
vraie question c'est la question de la
présence de la république c'est faisons
des citoyens les gens qui serait
différent et ça nous empêche pas de
penser différemment et on peut croire
nous pas croire croire en ce que l'on
veut dans la sphère privée ou dans la
sphère publique sans faire preuve de la
volonté personnelle les autres de
rattache de se rattacher à une religion
ou même année des politiques mais
faisons en sorte que le creuset
républicain et soyhières soi même pour
tous c'est ce qui l'a dénoncé c'était
l'incapacité qu'il avait de pouvoir
porter cette parole là peut-être hôtels
tels troubles en tant que pédagogue mais
de pouvoir dire je ne me sentais pas en
cas passer le faire nous mêmes en
sécurité de le faire sécurité
peut pas nier voyageant par les moyens
tout à leur disant parfois on a des
craintes quand on va dans des collèges
enfin moi je l'étais dans un collège à
paris au lycée qui étaient venus ces
mobiles barre dans le 19ème et je
représentais les élèves au lycée j'y
suis retourné pour des raisons
professionnelles et donc je suis
retourné mon propre collège kolev
palissé et quand je suis dans le collège
le directeur du collège me dire monsieur
majorité sont des pas dans la course
avec la récréation de lits mais pourquoi
pas
compliqué c'est pas comme à votre époque
mais pourquoi c'est pas mon époque c'est
le même collège c'est les mêmes gens
j'en viens donc c'est bien changé donc
après il ya la sécurité le sentiment
d'insécurité on va dire que le sentiment
d'insécurité les sentiments
d'impuissance d'aidé
enfin voir à l'époque j'avais deux tons
des sandales à la cour il a émis ces
défis à 3 baffes et les trois coups de
pied au cul et ça sera arrêtée on en
n'est plus la reine peut pas donc c'est
lors il faut qu'on réagisse tout ce
qu'on se dise que d'abord on arrête de
remettre en cause deux constats à ok un
constat et maintenant on applique des
solutions et on essaie tous ensemble est
autour de la table pour trouver des
solutions comme on le fait dans les
considérations des collèges des lycées
comme le font certains professeurs comme
le faire les différentes opérations
menées en place pour faire en sorte que
les règles en tout plus de monde puisse
s'exprimer et il faut il faut surtout ce
que ce que dit cet enseignant c'est ce
qu'on prend très bien son malaise c'est
que il est totalement anormal qu'un
professeur de philosophie ne puisse pas
débattre de tout dans sa classe ses jeux
c'est le minimum c'est le prérequis en
deux volets le tout jeune à parler de
tout et là on ne veut plus il devrait
parler vrai ou pas se cacher quand des
rumeurs si vous parlez de ça ça va
mettre telle communauté mal à l'aise si
vous parlez ça ça va créer un débat
qu'on pourra pas gérer etc et ce n'est
pas possible et donc là ce qu'on ne peut
que le soutenir quand il quand il fait
ce ce constat là on ne peut plus parler
de tout n'importe où et c'est totalement
anormal quand
j'ai pas grand chose à dire sur la
situation
on est on est sur les békés des
problématiques qu'on connaît
non je
vous lis et interview de ce jeu chez les
hommes à noter une chose bravo il
n'existe encore des coiffeurs mix tatra
on s'interroge déjà sur le sujet c'est
une première je te l'avais dit il avait
dit non s'interroge quand même sur le
sujet on ne pourra aussi s'interroger
sur le sujet que vous trouverez très
rarement des femmes un ton départ de
trappes mais il ya également d'autres
phénomènes qu'on pourra observer mois
celui que j'observe c'est celui de la
politique de notre pays parce que c'est
la politique d'un pays qui peut créer un
moment on en mode des déstabilisations
les déstabilisations n'arrive pas tout
seul la question qu'on doit se poser
c'est pourquoi on importe une seule et
même population une seule et même
culture ou encore une seule et même
religion souvent c'est les trois
combinés sur un même territoire il faut
mettre des seuils par exemple de
logements sociaux à l'intérieur des
territoires il faut dire par exemple
dans l'église on met pas plus que 30 ou
40 % de logements sociaux intérieur d'un
territoire comme ça il peut y avoir une
vraie simulation comment vous voulez
assimiler sans la population d'origine
on voulait où les populations qui sont
là depuis bien plus longtemps les
personnes qui viennent d'arriver c'est
pas possible vous avez besoin d'être mis
dans le bain et ce n'est pas le cas et
on est face à une culture et une
religion qui a un droit propre qui a une
vision est une organisation de la
société propre et qui a une position
établie sur certains sujets alors
forcément quand vous mettez toutes ces
personnes ensemble il ya un
endoctrinement de masse et de groupes
qui est fait comme on peut l'observer
sur tous les phénomènes de groupe et
d'endoctrinement comme des bandes de
jeunes violents est ce que cela vais
c'est qu'on ne peut plus comme il a été
dit on ne peut plus débattre de tous les
sujets parce qu'il ya des générations
interdit
de petites choses à dire d'abord sur les
barres enfin au delà la question des
femmes il ya beaucoup de bars dans le
périgord au fin fond de la france où les
femmes sont pas nous on est bienvenu en
général
le man ray sont les bienvenus
j'écoutais différence à peu des plans de
la question du logement ça tombe bien je
suis déléguée à l'habitat donc je peux
en parler un petit peu de ce que c'est
que le logement social par exemple saint
quentin en yvelines et plus généralement
dans les îles de rester avec nous mais
nous en tout cas on est on est on est
favorable aussi acquis et du hlm partout
et une meilleure répartition le prime
c'est qu'il ya des villes qui ne veulent
pas du hlm ne nie pas ce qu'ils veulent
pas du hlm bah c'est forcément nouveau
ville populaire qui recueille ont toutes
les populations dont les accueillent
très bien on prend notre part on
aimerait que les villes aussi un peu
plus riches souvent les villes souvent
de droite fasse aussi au moins les 25%
les horribles 25% des hlm faut qu'il
puisse accueillir toute la population et
qu'après on ne viennent pas nous voir
nous à nous dire qu'on est des ghettos
lors qu'ils opposent les ghettos de
jusqu'à présent dans la musicalité puis
choisir et non pas que soit l'état qui
prennent 80 bourses ont des attributions
des logements vd il faudrait faire
éclater leur dernier fait l'exact eau et
révèle sans couronne pour pour conclure
parce que après il va falloir qu'on se
fit malheureusement en quelques en
quelques secondes c'est cette idée du
creuset républicain elle est présente à
l'école elle est présente dans le
logement elle est présente dans les
bassins d'emploi et est la vraie
question c'est pas de se dire à combien
de pourcentage on met les logements
sociaux où le nombre d'enfants issus de
telle ou telle minorité dans les classes
c'est plutôt de se dire comment est ce
qu'on fait en sorte que les stratégies
des fins ce qu'on appelle les stratégies
d'évitement qui existe beaucoup dans les
pour les attributions des établissements
scolaires je viens d'une ville sans la
citer ou où les parents sont devenus
maîtres en la matière avec soin la mise
des enfants dans les institutions
privées pour passer dans le public soit
avec des multiples aux adresses pour
pouvoir être dans le bon établissement
je pense que là où on a échoué depuis
quelques dizaines d'années c'est qu'on
n'a pas donné envie aux gens de vivre
ensemble quand on installe et c'est vrai
tous les logements sociaux dans le même
quartier on a des stratégies d'évitement
qui sont mis en place par toutes les
populations qui le peuple et qui le
veulent et certaines voudrait pouvoir
aller s'installer ailleurs pour se
rapprocher de leur emploi ou des
établissements scolaires un peu plus
prestigieux pour paris m leurs enfants
et n'en ont pas les moyens donc l'idée
c'est plutôt de donner à tout le monde
l' envie de vivre ensemble et de
restreindre
non pas la capacité de choisir librement
le lieu où on habite vous met ses
enfants à l'école mais en tout cas faire
en sorte qu'ils aient plus d'incitations
à vivre ensemble à travailler ensemble
et à
mettre ses enfants dans les mêmes
établissements plutôt que toujours
cherché à trouver les moyens de
permettre à certains de vos tournées au
poulet les règles en un mot vincent
couronne moi je dirais qu'il faut
renvoyer au livre la politique à la
religion
oui mais en fait pour effectivement on
parle on parle de religion au moi je
suis assez d'accord avec eux ce que
disait jean charles lajoie lit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire quand il parlait de
cet enseignant donc didier de mer qui
n'étaient pas forcément très bien
compris de ses élèves je pense que c'est
un élément fondamental en fait c'est la
pédagogie voile en tant qu'enseignant je
n'ai jamais rencontré aucun problème
vis-à-vis des étudiants d'une
intolérance le sujet qu'on pouvait pas
aborder simplement parce que je pense
que si j'accepte leur y dépend si je si
je ne sais si j'accepte en fait qu'il
puisse débattre de leurs propres idées
il accepte ensuite en retour qu'on
débatte de des idées que moi je remet
sur la table et qui peuvent parfois les
heurter les heurter et ça c'est de la
pédagogie et il faut que tout le monde
puisse heureux se poser dès que des
bonnes questions etc et il me semble et
pour terminer avec le livre que se
livrent donc politique religion et
laïcité donc ils seront aujourd'hui donc
des surligneurs en librairie est un
livre qui est justement aborde tous les
sujets sur la religion et de manière
extrêmement neutre c'est-à-dire qu'on
dit en fait quel est l'état du droit
quel état de la pensée aujourd'hui sur
ces sujets là et ensuite une fois qu'on
a les outils on peut en débattre
décembre c'est la pédagogie essai
salvateur pour la démocratie non
lcd et les deux idées à leurs nerfs
optiques et voilà là le poké de l'état
partie convoitises et est passé merci
infiniment à tous dès 6 et on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de boeuf
[Musique]